en el vídeo anterior calculamos el
retorno real poniendo todo en términos
de dinero actual hicimos la reinversión
de 100 dólares pero con dinero actual y
después calculamos nuestro retorno
actual es decir nuestro retorno en dólar
con respecto al dinero actual y
obtuvimos nuestro retorno real ahora en
lo que quiero pensar en este vídeo es de
qué otra manera podemos hacerlo me
parece interesante poner todo el dinero
del año pasado así que tenemos estos 110
dólares pongamos los 110 dólares del
dinero actual pero ahora calculemos esos
110 dólares para dinero del año pasado y
para pensar en esto podríamos hacer un
poco de álgebra o bueno no tienes que
hacer álgebra pero el álgebra siempre lo
hace un poco más intuitivo hay una
cierta cantidad de dinero el año pasado
llamémosle x entonces está el que x lo
multiplicamos por la tasa de inflación
es decir a x lo aumentamos por el 2% es
a ser igual a 110 dólares de hoy o
resolvemos para x dividimos ambos lados
por 1.02 y así obtenemos la cantidad de
dinero que si lo aumentamos por inflar
o que tenía el mismo poder adquisitivo
de 110 dólares el día de hoy
ahora calculadoras sería igual a 110
mejor lo muevo a la derecha 110 dólares
/ 110 / 1.02 lo cual es igualdad 107.8
aproximadamente para redondearlo
entonces x es igual a 107.8 dólares
así que 110 dólares hoy nos compran
exactamente si crees en todo eso de el
index cpi nos compran 107 dólares con 8
centavos le agrego el otro decimal a
punto 84 entonces 107 dólares con 84
centavos
no os comprarían el año pasado lo que
110 dólares nos comprarían hoy así que
cuál es el retorno en dólar para el
dinero del año pasado
cuál es el retorno en dólar del año
pasado muy bien pues nos quedamos con
107 dólares con 84 centavos entonces
tenemos 107
con 84 centavos en dinero del año pasado
y habíamos originalmente invertido en
dinero del año pasado 100 dólares así
que tenemos que nuestro retorno en dólar
es de 7 dólares con 84 centavos o si
quieres calcular el retorno real que es
el aumento de nuestro poder adquisitivo
actual
bueno pues obtuvimos 7.84 dólares
retorno en dólar de una inversión de 100
dólares y eso es bastante fácil de
calcular nuevamente obtenemos el 7.8 por
ciento para nuestro retorno real